welcome to the lobby i am not danny
o'dwyer i'm justin haywald danny
unfortunately could not be with us he is
doing some super secret stuff that
hopefully you'll hear about more later
this week in the meantime you have to
put up with me and some guys that i have
on the couch i have mike mchardy and ty
root joining me to talk about lots of
exciting things we're going to be
talking about some deus ex some star
wars but first we're going to kick it
off with some hearts of the stone
hearthstone heart hearts of stone hearts
hearthstone we're going to talk about
the witcher expansion
hearts of stone yes
do you think it's a joke that they
called it hearts of stone do you think
they're trying to go with hearthstone or
is this is this tied in so the hearts of
stone expansion is out now you've
already played it you you reviewed it
for us yeah and ty i know you're excited
to try it out yes why do you why is it
called hearts of stone
um there's a few they
say that specific phrase a few times but
there's a few characters who kind of i
think it's kind of like a character
study of geralt how he's kind of
incapable of loving people although you
can love people in this expansion i
loved a lot of people i thought the
whole point of the witcher is is loving
people yes you love people
and i loved a whole house of women once
in the witcher 3.
and uh yeah so sorry mary one of the
villains there's a kind of a couple of
villains and they are both just
heartless i guess that's how it ties in
i would imagine because one of the
person people who says that phrase to
girl is ends up being kind of a
jerk so so you get to learn a little bit
more about geraldton and
it's a very story focused expansion this
is this isn't something that adds a lot
of new gameplay elements
very few um you do get runecrafting
which is just another way to kind of
affect how you use signs so axie now the
one that stuns people or turns them
against their allies you can kind of
chain it if you kill them in a certain
amount of time it'll chain the next
person but yeah those things are all
kind of minuscule compared to the story
and everything um here you'll see uh you
know hopefully spoiler free gameplay
right now but you do a lot of things
that kind of cater to
what made the witcher 3's main game so
good it was just each quest had a lot of
substance and how they told their
stories and these self-contained
you know little asides that played into
the main story like quest really well
and the characters are awesome um pretty
much everyone you meet you meet shawnee
here's uh that was olgierd von evrick
this is
there's shawnee right here in the scene
as well as uh
gauntero dim who he's one of the people
you have no idea the whole time what
their motivation he doesn't look evil at
all he doesn't
most of the time until he does this to
your face he marks you like because
you're kind of
his
lackey
for there is a probably a different term
i could have used but yeah so a lot of
times you're carrying out quests for him
whether you want to or not does it go
into geralt's history about why he likes
redheads so much no i just think so not
that i remember he
in his workout routine yeah he talks
about his like crossfit training yeah he
does he does crossfit he drinks pro
complex when he's been working out five
star so i know shawnee is one of the
characters that you're most interested
in learning and seeing more uh
yeah i mean i i've always appreciated
the witcher just because of its story
it's it's weird because i've i've now
hit that shroud where i've been playing
so much metal gear for so long for like
over 60 hours where i'm i'm now really
i now yearn for a good story i want a
actual good story in a game because the
the metal gears is just complete dog
[ __ ] sorry
but the gameplay is amazing some people
might argue with you they're dumb
they're wrong um that story's horrible
but regardless the witcher has that's
what grabbed me always was the story and
you can see that throughout the entire
game the actual main game not just even
the um the dlc
is that they borrow from so much like
fairy tales literature
certain tropes obviously they're gonna
like you know touch upon but it's
nothing like but they always kind of
have their own spin on it you know it's
always something unique um
and their side quests are so good and
like they're interesting and the stories
behind them are interesting and yeah you
can approach all these characters
different ways
but um one thing that i've always loved
about the witch and i admired about it
is that it does make you care about the
people and the characters um the
gameplay is good it's not like
revolutionary but obviously it's the
story that actually grabs me and so i i
it's is this a continuation of his story
or is it like before the events of wild
hunt it's kind of just during the wild
hunt
it's recommended level 30 but you pretty
much will just get a prompt for uh to go
to this bulletin board in a town and
then you'll meet someone there that's
like oh come by old geared von everex
manor and he'll tell you more and that
kind of sets off a few different quest
lines that you go through with a main
one and a few side ones because the game
is so story focused it's hard to talk
about it and i think not spoil things
but you did give the game overall a nine
yeah it's awesome it's really good i
mean it the pacing is
excellent um
it's also like tai had mentioned it
really like the witcher 3 in general
plays on like you know fantasy tropes
and whatnot this one really pushes that
but each of them kind is very subversive
in the way they tell them you know
there's the prince and the frog which
i guarantee you that fairy tale has
never been told the way that cd projekt
red does it here um
there's
this character who's very very
terrifying it looks like something from
uh like pants labyrinth i like that you
cut away from this right before he
reveals his face yeah that's gross he's
gone yeah
but like within the first two hours
you're fighting three different bosses
like mini bosses and they're all unique
in their own ways but you go to a
wedding and it sounds boring and there
were a few
um you know
i kind of had a few complaints with
these mini games that you're kind of
forced into but they don't last that
long and they're very minor in the grand
scheme of things but it's just very
funny the wedding plays out like a
sitcom in a fantasy world then you do a
heist it feels like grand theft auto if
you know or ocean's 11 if it was in you
know middle earth or something
or the northern kingdoms i guess to be
more specific so there's a lot of kind
of a
lot of different things you can do kind
of coalesce in an awesome way yeah you
mentioned in your review that maybe the
mini games and the detective sections
didn't meld quite as well yeah the
detective sections i always
felt like they were forced in the main
game i guess it plays into girl like the
witcher's abilities the characters yeah
but these ones were almost
with like one exception i think there
were eight of them that i went through
and each one was just
follow this blood trail to 20 feet away
and find this thing that i could have
just seen with my eyes as a human
without you know those
cat eyes there's a character that calls
you twist peepers and i assume that's
because you're cat eyes but
maybe it's just a northern kingdom slang
for
something meaner
and so this is kind of a precursor to
more which are content that we're going
to be getting in early 2016 the blood
and wine expansion and that's going to
expand the story out even more this was
about 10 hours i think and the blood and
wine expansion is going to continue that
by even 20 hours what kind of additional
things do you want to see in the game
um i just like to see more of these
quests that fit it was
hearts of stone fit pretty seamlessly
into the main game and i'd like to see
that continue but at the same time i'd
also would not mind as you know by the
time blood and wine comes out you said
it was quarter one or no just first half
first time for now it's first half of
2016. you used to be q1 now
maybe maybe a little later sometime in
2016 before summer so with almost a year
removed from the witcher 3's full
release i would not mind seeing them do
kind of either a prequel or a you know
continuation of the main story because i
think this
like during the fall release schedule
this was a good time for someone to say
hey if you want to pay 10 for quest it's
going to fit into the game
go for it but later on down the road
we're going to give you something that's
going to reward you for having beat the
game or kind of have knowing these
characters maybe we'll go back to see
what was going on before this i would
not mind that at all and i think that
would work
and ty for someone who does i i think in
your job you don't get to play his games
as often as no as a lot of us do
but this is something to enjoy them you
know it's really cool you've played a
lot of the witcher 3. yeah what is it
that keeps you going along and do you
think that just in more story is that
enough to pull you into yeah i mean i i
just think it's about taking a break
right i mean i think the the beautiful
thing about this expansion and then the
next one is that they're they're timed
far apart enough for me to kind of want
to go back into that world and actually
see what geralt's up to now i mean and
i'd like to see more i love the politics
behind this game i love that that the
story of this game is not so much about
what is happening
with uh with like siri's dad and the
emperor and and nova grad it's more
about or roach and that whole thing into
mario it's more about what geralt wants
right but all these political
themes and and and snowballs are kind of
like in place you know like about to
like explode at some point so you have
all this stuff kind of going on around
you but it's not really it doesn't mean
much to you as your character you just
kind of observe it i'd like to see what
happens now like depending on what
actions happen at the end of your game
like for example i'm gonna spoil
everything for something now so you just
turn this off you don't listen to it but
in my game siri takes over as empress
right so i would love to see um what
happens after that like like how is she
as an emperor you know or an empress
like does she does she rule more fairly
than her father you know her father
killed a bunch of people in my game and
kind of pissed some people off but she
takes over
how does her now political leanings
affect the story and then the world
around you you know and also like
there's so many awesome side quests in
that game like there i remember this
there's this one where you have no idea
of what you're doing is like good or bad
but like some ladies like hey
it's it's another spoiler i'm warning
you now turn this off uh he's like throw
this baby in the oven just [ __ ] trust
me you know you're like uh okay and you
have like split seconds to react right
but those stories are so engaging and
they all kind of like come together to
like really help something so and like
help progress the story you're in your
character and it's just it's it's really
really good storytelling and so i'd love
to see more of that well last question
if you're still here and you did not
turn off even though ty kept telling you
to turn away i'm going to spoil [ __ ]
what what is the most surprising thing
that you can say without spoiling
something that you think people are
going to be really surprised to have
seen in the gamer that it was a really
kind of shocking or a big moment for you
um
there was a brief glimpse of it during
the gameplay but i don't think if you
don't know what's going on it won't make
sense there's a part where you are not
in
well obviously the whole game you're not
in the real world but you're not in the
game's world anymore you go to this kind
of metaphysical dimension
and it was crazy but it worked so well
and somehow they made it work and i
think that was my favorite part it was
kind of it was just this alternate
universe that was gorgeous but also
kind of scary as [ __ ] it was there you
saw that guy about the eliza hood that
part was scary yeah just like fighting
him and seeing him is bad there's always
there's a lot of those like weird creepy
moments in this game like that little uh
really what are they called the
botchling the botchling oh the first
time i saw that
was awful but that's not in the new one
so yeah but there's always like
something new like that and weird oh i
would also love to hear more um i always
the the elven sage that helps siri
throughout the entire story again
spoiler you have five seconds to turn
this off
turn this off okay anyway uh that elven
sage apparently you know i like to know
about his world where he comes from he
helped kind of like one of the wild hunt
guys was like a student it'd be kind of
cool to kind of explore that yeah
there's a lot of cool interpersonal ties
yeah and that was a
surprisingly uh a talk that we kept on
track and did not go into inappropriate
things which i thought might have been
more likely hearts of stone is out now
you should go check it out and as soon
as you get the chance to play we'd love
to hear what you think how are you
enjoying this extension of the witcher 3
and so next up uh before we before we go
on to our next seven thank you so much
mike and ty we're gonna see a trailer
for something that was just now today a
kickstarter for a friday the 13th game
let's check it out
after it happened i expected someone to
do something
i expected parents to show up with
questions and concerns
i thought the police would have done
more
but nothing happened
nothing changed
quiet someone will
they opened it again
the next year
and they were back to their old habits
troy
did you hear something relax babe
probably just steve trying to scare us
they're just kids right so was he
he was just an innocent boy
i was a good mother to him
my boy
my sweet
sweet
jason
that's some good timing friday the 13th
as a kickstarter right as we're going
into some halloween festivities but next
up on the lobby we're going to be
talking about the star wars season pass
announcement the beta is wrapping up you
have a couple more hours to get into
that but for you ostensibly like there's
no more time to play but we did learn a
lot more about the season pass i'm
joined on the couch by mike mccarty rob
handlery and aaron
what do you guys think so having played
a lot of time with the beta that was
extended
much longer than we thought it was going
to be what are your overall impressions
so nine they said today nine million
people played the beta to me that says
that this was a demo
a lot of times i think that they do say
beta when this is in fact a demo the
game is so close to launch it's going to
be coming out soon this might be a
little bit of testing the servers and
stressing them and making sure that they
work but for the game itself this is the
the fully finished product this is the
game as it's so that's that's what i
went into it assuming like this late in
the in the cycle like i'm sure the discs
are already going off to print and you
know people who have their pre-orders
and are making their decisions right
about now whether to keep them or ditch
them
i i mostly was left with kind of a
little bit of concern
from the beta
we saw three maps
um and rob's also seen endor and every
single time we've seen this game
there's always been just
something to every single map where
you're like
i'm not so sure about this like walker
assault on hoth
was so imbalanced towards the imperials
and and to be fair to beta and balance
can be tweaked and fixed but in this
case i don't know how it got through qa
to that point like i wonder what the
creative process was
that allowed the imperials to have their
atsd walkers literally walk into the
rebel spawn the spawn kill everybody or
like a turret that fired directly into
the rebel base and killed everybody or
an atat walker that fired into the rebel
base and killed everybody like and you
can't choose your spawn it's something
as simple as not even letting players
choose where they're going to start to
get to the objective granted you could
you could spawn on a partner
but you know you think of battlefield
like
spawning or lobby menus there's at least
a freaking map like you know what i mean
like i would actually that's what i'm
just realizing now is you know there
isn't a map to see what's what's going
on in the battlefield field right now
where are my guys what tactical location
can i come in and help out it's just so
up in the air like you know we put
footage up of like an atsc
rampage i had as an imperial
and i just flanked
around on the side lane
and just started owning people i got
like 15 kills because
they're spawning in groups like you know
six guys at once and i'm just
annihilating them and there's nothing
they can do they have no control over
their spawning so that was that was just
like the walker slot on hoth drop zone
on solast
was just like a model of simplicity and
it was so simple and the pacing was so
consistent that i i tend to find those
things get boring just because the map
didn't have any terrain variety to it it
was all lava fields with little pools
that burned your ankles and one landing
pad with a ship you couldn't interact
with so like maybe that that might be
dice's so like in battlefield what they
would do is they would take a large map
and section off a small area for team
deathmatch style modes so it's possible
that map to be fair is much larger and
has interesting sections and that was
just a boring section to pick for the
map
um and then survival on tatooine they
only allowed normal mode and in normal
mode the enemy ai like would fall asleep
fighting you like i had an atsd just
kind of drift off in the middle of a gun
battle and like kind of lost focus on
board yeah like like so again like all
of the things that were curated for this
demo
i just
i just found problems with but overall i
mean this is something that is at the
end of the day it's a marketing tool
it's trying to get you to to try out the
game and enough people played it you
said over nine million people and they
extended it long enough that it seems
like on that sense it was a
success mike
what do you think after having played it
is this something that you feel like i i
want to pre-order it or are you still
kind of waiting for it to see what the
review is going to shake out to be i
don't know that i would pre-order i
didn't play as extensively as these two
or a few people in the office but i had
fun with it i wasn't i don't know that i
went into it looking for like a balance
as much as i would with a lot of
shooters but it was just great to be
back in the star wars universe but will
that get me
excited to pay for the season pass and
pre-order the game i don't think so i
think i would hesitate yeah so you're
not gonna buy the season pass from this
i'm not i'm probably gonna handle it
just like i did with battlefield four uh
i bought i bought battlefield four
and then bought one expansion and then
you know i got i drifted away i've been
again i'm not like a i used to be insane
battlefield guy but so that's my only
reason there but
buying a hundred and twenty dollars
worth for this game
and having this beta experience you
there's no way there's no way you would
do it but you you mentioned this is like
the battlefield experience and then it's
going to follow that same
that same setup that same algorithm
where you have four packs we don't know
exactly what's going to be offered in
them but there's going to be some
assortment probably of of new maps and
maybe some some new modes um
having seen that from the the
battlefield model why is that not
something that you want to carry over
into star wars
traditionally i mean you can speak this
but go for it yeah i mean traditionally
battlefield 3 and 4 had at least one dlc
that i didn't like
they were mostly had to do with taking a
large battlefield and making it too
close quarters um they did that twice in
a row on their first dlc
and so already like i had already paid
for one of four dlcs that i didn't like
ahead of time so i've i've gotten to a
point now where i'm i'll wait and just
see how the dlc is before i'll buy it
and if there's even one dlc that you
don't like you've like saved yourself 15
or whatever out of
you know the pricing model right
now
again like this game though is very
simple i think it's very casual and i
think of those 9 million people
like you pretty much know right away
whether you like it or not because the
design decisions are so specific not
being able to choose your spawn not
having extensive loadouts
you know like having the game
choose when and where you go a lot of
times
you you'll know whether you like that or
not right away and i think that that
won't be a hard decision for casual
players to make yeah
i just wanted to say we're seeing a lot
of aerial combat uh i did a video piece
the aerial combat is so
confusing
it needed to be one-to-one like so for
instance when you see a barrel roll it's
just such a weird design choice when you
do a barrel i'm sorry an barrel a flip
you're gonna be upside down
the game doesn't know like it then has
to be like okay well now i'm upside down
how the hell do i get back right side up
your controls are the same for left and
right and that
yaw and roll are the same in one
direction so you're upside down the the
controls are just so weird and bizarre
here you are uh
automatically being swung into a hill
when you're doing the snow speeder
i i don't know it's so was that 88 was
that 88 pretty much invulnerable to
those to the tow cable when it was next
to that hill it becomes vulnerable in
the very very last portion of the fight
in which you can toe cable it and
oftentimes the timer would run out while
you're in the qte
so even though you would have cinched
the walker you would lose because the
timer ran out
like again it's these you have a demo
you have a curated demo and what you've
shown is mostly concerning me
um and
you know when you ask the question about
pre-orders that means no i'm not going
to pre-order it now i'm open to the
possibility that they're good that
there's going to be good modes and maps
in this game
um there's a couple things that i'm
looking forward to like supremacy is
going to be their conquest mode and it's
the sort of tug-of-war conquest mode so
that actually could be really cool
um cargo
sounds a lot like capture the flag or
obliteration from battlefield hardline
obliteration was a great mode in
battlefield 4. and droid run
might solve the problems of drop zone by
it looks like it like the droids move
around right so instead of just guarding
static things the the droids are running
around so like already there's like
that's probably about half of the modes
that i'm interested in
the other half the modes when i flip
through the menus i am definitely not
interested in like their team deathmatch
not interested in air supremacy their
fighter squadron mode
like not interested in so you know like
there's half the content that i'm
like tentatively looking forward to
seeing
well in rob as one of the biggest star
wars fans in the office
i think that there there has to be some
deals there has to be some maps or
something that you're like right even
even though i'm on the fence now like as
soon as the announcement no i have to
order that as soon as i know that's in
the game exactly and that's that's where
i'm on the fence i'm
so looking forward to this movie i
watched the trailer about like five
times every day
but the movie you know as you can
imagine the seasons are gonna um
correspond to the movie you're gonna see
like you know in the trailer the x-wings
booking in on the water probably going
to be in our security or superiority map
you're going to have these correlations
with like oh man that would be really
cool what a what a memorable moment from
the movie that i'd love to play that's
where i'll probably get
i'll get sucked in but i'm i i gotta
play the game the actual game first i'm
not gonna make that call 120 bucks is
way too much is there anything that
would pull you in mike yeah i mean like
aaron had said i think i'm just more the
person who would want to see how each
individual pack plays out uh i would not
mind spending 15 dollars for you know
another planet to play on or however
they choose to separate it and whatnot
but and i'm nowhere near as close as rob
or like a bunch of people in the office
i'm a huge star wars fan but i
i just can't
i don't know what they would need to do
for me to just say yes i will pre-order
it i will pay 120 so i can prolong this
experience for that long
because right now it seems bareboned
from my impression i've played a few
hours i haven't played a ton and i don't
see that being worth that money
but i'm hoping they can
convince me well last question for each
of you guys we've had some leaks come
out of the game that we know there's
going to be some additional characters
han
and leia the emperor as hero powers
they're going to be able to get and
possibly some new skins for for those
hero powers as well
what kind of additions like that would
you like to see in the game like whether
it's even possible or not or whether
it's realistic what what's your kind of
dream wish if you throw boba fett in
there oh he's coming in yeah
he is yeah as a hero
as uh you can control him in the slave
one and as well as uh
the real deal yeah those words or
widgets
assault
don't take your selfie seriously just
dude how about just give me wampa's how
about that uh what's that character name
the like you seen the trailer like the
like the um
uh silver stormtrooper
captain like asthma i think yeah he
looked like a dark trooper the first
time i saw him he'd be awesome
he might be a lady trooper
oh she is yeah cool it's the girl from
what's her name from um brienne of tarth
game of thrones thank you yeah yeah she
totally kicks ass and those are a lot of
cool things that we might see
potentially i think they take our ideas
i think they listen to us and those are
the things they're going to put into the
game star wars battlefront launches on
november november 17th one month after
that you're able to see the force
awakens in theaters on december 18th and
for even more game spot or for even more
star wars stuff stay tuned to game spot
all right next up we have a cool trailer
for you guys to check out
it's not necessarily related assassin's
creed syndicate has some historical
characters that they've added to the
game and we'll get to see those in this
newest trailer
by 1868 london was the center of the
largest empire the world had ever known
the city attracted the greatest thinkers
from all parts of the world each an ally
who will help you fight against
exploitation
alexander graham bell scottish inventor
and engineer inspired by the deafness of
loved ones he studied acoustics and was
one of the early inventors of the
telephone and other modern marvels i've
been working in something that's meant
to stun an assailant
it's a blessing that you employ your
genius for the common good alec
karl marx the author of the communist
manifesto in his writing and in speeches
spent his life fighting for the rights
of workers i challenge you both to help
those who really need your assistance
the working people we accept shouldn't
we at least talk about these things
sod it we accept
charles darwin father of the theory of
evolution his ideas defied popular
thinking about the origin of species i
am used to people challenging my ideas
in fact i live for it lately however
attacks have taken a darker turn
charles dickens in oliver twist and
other tales the novelist highlighted the
plight of the poor opening the eyes of
the city's inhabitants to the
deprivation around them here we are in
the world's most advanced city yet its
citizens leave themselves vulnerable to
charlatans
is there a doctor nearby
bring her inside florence nightingale
her vision took nursing out of the home
and turned it into a profession and set
the standard for modern healthcare
queen victoria came to embody the
century she was known as the grandmother
of europe her majesty and her 64-year
reign saw the entire century dubbed the
victorian era i call upon you to foil
this traitorous plot now it's your turn
to make history discover the secrets
behind london's greatest men and women
the work begins immediately
will you join us
not every problem can be solved by
blowing things sky-high
what's the fun in that
pre-order now at amazon for access to
the darwin and dickens conspiracy
reserve now available october 23rd
next up we're going to be talking about
the halo 5 launch trailer that we saw
recently we learned a lot of halo news
recently i'm joined on the couch by mike
maherty and rob handlery now you guys
are some of the biggest halo fans we
have in the office and i'm sure you guys
have seen the trailer multiple times
what did we we saw a little bit of new
stuff a little bit of the old stuff what
was new in this trailer we were talking
about this morning just like different
enemy types that we weren't completely
familiar with we were wondering what
those guys in the white were but i think
we start talking about the prometheans
right right so it was like this
promethean character um i found out his
name is called the warden or he's a
class of promethean um having played
warzone game mode a couple times one a
few times at e3
those are some of the guys the ai uh
elements of the mode
where you essentially you know you team
up with hey
so and so let's go out here and
basically stomp over this
ai boss like figure to you know break up
points for your team so those promethean
guys i was looking i was watching the
trailer as well and they looked very
destiny-like because were those the
characters you're talking about the kind
of
destiny yes but
in
uh halo 343's defense prometheans
started in halo 4.
so it's more destiny is stealing that
that original yeah so bungee just
cherry-picking from everyone i don't
even think that's the correct use of the
word cherry-picking but uh yeah they're
the you know the digitally reconstructed
people they kind of look like uh elites
as if they got uh right the didact you
know made them into prometheans just
through that process i forget what's
called but yeah and then the entire
trailer was set to uh muses knights of
cydonia it was so good which is really
great old song and a lot of people are
saying they don't want that song near
halo or a video game in general but tell
me you don't watch this trailer and just
get amped as hell for this they were
especially when otimo cyrus was just
jumping down the hill shotguning people
in the face and then it's like
it's awesome
it kicks in like right here and then oh
man it's i'm yeah i'm amped it was
it was good well one thing we have not
gotten a lot from this trailer and we
haven't learned a lot in general but
we're still getting these little hints
is where this story is going we see
master chief when we get this that there
is some kind of conflict with lock and
there's the the other halo teams and and
mike you are really into halo lore
you've read a lot of these books like
you know the two back in the front ends
like rom i think you were saying that
you you've played a lot of halo games
but maybe not to the extent of yeah i
mean books i've played them all uh and i
and i felt like i knew the story pretty
well and this game was one of the first
times where it spun me around a little
bit and it's like wait who's oh cyrus
team i get i know um
uh buck was from odst correct yeah like
certain characters i i recognize but um
you know who is this team that master
chief has and that pertains to the lore
and the books you know i i mean i looked
it up i had to do my little wiki
research obviously but like you know you
find out that
um
that this team is you know they're like
they're the original spartan twos the um
they grew up and trained with master
chief
and uh that's pretty cool i mean i hope
i hope to play the game and they tap on
a lot of that you know uh backstory yeah
you can go into more i'm sure michael oh
yeah no you you're right there these are
pretty much the last few spartan twos
you know in the first in halo combat
evolved the first game you think that
master chief is the last one and then
you find out that if when you you know
after uh halo reach you find out a few
of them survive but uh halo the fall of
reach uh eric nylon wrote it it was just
a prequel to um
the first halo and that's these are some
of the original people even before they
got the muscle augmentation so they
could wear the suit because if a normal
human wears that suit their reflex will
be so fast they'll break a bone and then
react to that break another bone just
kind of kill yourself
really fast it's gruesome in the book
but they need to get these muscle
augmentations and a lot of them die off
from that but
i think it's fred linda and kelly
they're each kind of specialists fred or
is it sam no you had right okay so fred
is just the big like strong one and uh
you know uh
lynn and kelly kind of fill out the fast
and sniper roles right and so it's kind
of this squad-based combat um anthony
longo was a lead designer on republic
commando the star wars game and now he's
working on halo 5 which kind of from
what i play to the campaign it's kind of
very much this
not a ton of tactics but you can tell
your teammates where to fire if you're
not playing co-op and you can tell them
you know regroup on me and you can kind
of take these branching paths and i
think that's kind of cool that it's
fitting into this narrative because
it seems like it's gonna be a frantic
narrative you know traditionally in
halos you're on this alien world or just
this ring world trying to figure things
out there's this mystery that's
propelling you forward even in halo 4
when you're on requiem but now this just
seems like it's straightforward just
team osiris [ __ ] chasing after the
chief and the chief you have no idea
like whether he's good or bad anymore
because
i i won't spoil the ending of halo 4 i
don't know how many people have finished
it but
something happens to the end of halo 4
that's going to mess with his head so
now he's kind of from what i've played
you're kind of
you're messed up and then you can see
that and you see the 343 is trying to
push that so i'm interested to see the
dynamic between blue team and osiris as
they're chasing chief well if they need
different teams and it sounds like
they're trying to solve a mystery they
probably should call in well maybe fred
velman shaggy
oh my god
i'm sorry
and then the ghostbusters come in and
start and wrecking people too
um but
yeah uh you know there was one trailer
where i saw it was it was
uh
the blue team in like a pelican going
somewhere
and chief's just like flying and like
the other three in the back they're like
dude she's kind of losing his mind right
yeah should we talk to him i'm like
what's going on with this guy and he's
you know he's just gung-ho i don't like
it
that's what's funny because these are
the people that he grew up with the
spartan 2 program was really messed up
uh katherine halsey's character would
come in abduct these kids who were
showing signs of promise clone them give
the clones to the parents she literally
took john from a playground yeah i'm not
kidding she went to a playground took
him put his clone on the playground that
clone went back to the parents they have
no idea that the actual john's been
missing hello father he went through
like spartan trips that's me john are
you okay today yes you seem a little off
ashley said no to that i don't know okay
so anyway um
so it's these are the people that he's
closest with his whole life aside from
you know cortana and it's interesting to
see them they come up and like put their
hands back like
dude you're all right are you are you
sure and then he's like
[ __ ] you we're going and everybody's
just
the entire human race is kind of like
this guy's losing his mind and we should
probably do something to stop him you
know and we'll learn a lot more about
the story as it goes along of course but
we did learn some more about how the
game itself will will shake out now
there's not going to be any big team
battle but they're taking that out of
the multiplayer playlist for for a
reason right i think the idea is that
when uh multiplayer kicks off they they
want people to really dive into the new
ones right warzone and arena um you know
all the dlc for halo 5 will be free so
it's like you know you don't have to
stress about that
um i think i if i recall big team
battles and more of the you know maybe
oddball are the ones that i didn't see
on the list
will come out down the road toward the
end of the year um so they're coming you
know and and personally warzone was so
much fun i
i'm really excited for that one
yeah i think it could be the one to
fill the gap left by a big team battle
right
but the thing that i think maybe people
are more concerned about in which bungie
that are
yeah bungie the developer has had to
confirm
three four three not bungie the people
on the left those are the ones who stole
the prometheans 343 has commented on
microtransactions and i think that can
always be kind of a sword that can be a
very big sticking point and in this
there is going to be a micro transaction
element where if you want to get these
requisition packs the wrecks
you can either use in-game currency or
you can spend real-world money how do
you guys feel about that
i i feel all right with what i mean
and this was the the looming question
was what's the conversion how much will
it cost to get rex and so we looked it
up just before and you know it's
uh well they released this a couple
weeks ago i think uh again the price
range was uh 2 000
wreck points for it was how much four
dollars three dollars
which basically correlates to
two games two 30-minute matches of
warzone that's that's nothing to me i
mean that's i'm okay with that yeah it
seems like you're getting a fair amount
of rewards from just playing yeah it
doesn't
i just inherently don't love micro
transactions in a game that's already 60
but i think this doesn't seem
awful um
it seems like you're getting rewarded
for the amount of time you play and it
doesn't seem like the money will speed
like push you past people in too big of
a way i think
it still will have a balance between
you're gonna play a lot of our game
we're going to reward you for it if you
want to pay go for it go for it if you
want it i think i think of it as you
know you have these three different
types of wreck cards you have your
cosmetics
assassinations those are permanent just
says unlocking certain weapons vehicles
are kind of the burn cards you know use
a mantis uh late game
but it comes down to
you can only if you were really gonna
get one of these items you know like a
mantis and you're gonna pay the three
dollars or whatever to get a couple
these guys you still have to do we have
to play well in order to unlock it on
the battlefield so it's there's still a
there's still a uh
like a roadblock that's basically
stopping people from just you know um
you know buying tons of amount of cards
and using whenever they want you can't
you have to be able to perform well in
the um in the warzone field in order to
pull them out so i'm okay with that yeah
it doesn't seem like it's kind of a pay
to win situation i mean maybe we'll find
out it is when we play the game more but
like you said i really don't think
that's the case at all from what like
the info they've given us it doesn't
seem like that's the case right and i do
wonder also um you know for the arena
mode
um
your paid like your burn cards aren't
there so the pay to win aspect is
completely unite
removed
i wonder if that's even going to be like
an option for like custom modes maybe
you can like turn
off any kind of like
aspects correlating to that you know
what i mean for like swat maybe you can
just get like down down and gritty and
just like have
you know just the basic um power weapons
on a map and that's it yeah so we'll see
i don't know well so my last question
talking about the story and you know
since we have someone who is so
knowledgeable of all the intricacies of
halo they've made a big deal of being
either team master chief team lock
where do you think the story is going
what is your wild fan theory for how
this is actually going to play out since
right now we don't have the game we
don't know what's going to happen
what what do you think's going to be
personally i would love to see chief
just lose his mind and
just be batshit crazy by the end and
then lock has to come in and then chief
still kills him and then you know halo 6
chief is just a lunatic so right it's a
it's a trilogy part uh i i did hear that
like this the rumor or like not remember
the the facts are that a lot of
questions are gonna be laid out then
more answered so yeah there's gonna be
there's gonna be probably some crazy
cliffhanger at the end of this just like
there was a halo two yeah it was just
like
oh god now i gotta wait i gotta wait
three two two more years for the next
one like uh yeah two finished with uh oh
yeah
and then it just cuts to the music i
could see obviously it's the reclaimer
trilogy and
chief is the reclaimer as for all
intents and purposes as far as we're led
to believe so
i and i think they're pushing narrative
ever since halo 4 i actually loved halo
4 story and i think that
it definitely will just leave three open
and maybe take that traditional trilogy
arc of the second one being the really
dark one and not necessarily you know
leaving the resolution open for the
third game the empire strikes back so to
speak yeah
two towers
um
empire strikes back i i well i said that
i'm interested to see where this is
gonna how this is gonna pan out mike uh
rob thanks so much for joining me uh for
all of you guys at home halo 5 launches
on october 27th that's coming up really
soon what do you think the story's going
to be how do you think this is all going
to pan out let us know and thanks for
watching so next up we got another
trailer we're going to see oh
oh rocket league
so there's some rocket league i know
some big fans of the office here
have you been playing the new back to
the future dlc no that's next that's the
trailer that we're going to watch
out there that's old news what we're
going to see now is some back to the
future delorean action i feel like an
idiot
ah
we've got to go back marty
well we're not back we we're back with
the lobby
smooth good segway that was a really
good segue i'm good at these the segways
i've had a lot of practice
you're doing great justin so i'm joined
on the couch for a new segment we're
going to be talking with some scott
butterworth matt espinelli these are two
of our big deus ex fans in the office
and scott you recently got the chance to
try out deus ex mankind divided this is
our first time getting hands on yeah you
had a big preview but overall what was
your what was your experience with it
uh
i guess my experience was basically if
you've played human revolution you you
pretty much know what you expect out of
mankind divided um it very much feels
like they are expanding on and iterating
on the ideas established in human
revolution and just more refining them
than reinventing them uh the mechanics
gonna feel very familiar to people who
played that game and of course anybody
who's played any of the deus ex games
really um but there was there was new
stuff to try out um there were a lot of
time to try you were in this one level
for for three hours yeah well so yeah if
anybody read the feature that went on uh
that went up on the site last thursday
um that was a completely true headline
uh the way that a lot of these preview
events work i mean they were nice enough
to bring us up to idos montreal to play
in the studio and generally in those
types of situations they have a very
specific portion of the game that they
are allowing us to play this is the part
that's not buggy that's not going to
crash that they've sort of like polished
a little bit so you can play it before
the game is actually done
so generally those sections are
relatively sure they're just to give you
a taste and an idea of what the game's
going to be like and so
typically because those sections are
short the amount of time you get to play
them is you know also short because they
expect you to get through it relatively
quickly that was not the case in
montreal uh interestingly they kind of
just let me loose on this level and
we're like yeah like you've got like
three or four hours you just kind of
play around do whatever you want uh so i
just
kept playing through it over and over
and try different things every time um
obviously one of the big hooks for
people who may not be familiar with the
games
you can kind of approach them in a
variety of ways i mean the two major
obvious ways to do it are you know
straight combat or straight stealth um
it is completely possible to play
through any deus ex game without killing
anybody um with the exception of boss
battles which we will get to
um but it's also possible to play
through like it's a traditional first
person shooter and just shoot and kill
everyone and blow things up and just
kind of run for it but it's not quite
like a like a hitman style stealth
different paths to choose kind of game
correct yeah um so that was what was
interesting about getting so much time
to play the game i really was able to
explore
all of the different options and all the
the different potential approaches that
you could take
you know one of the things i talk about
in the future that i think is
really
unique to the deus ex series is
just how detailed and dense the level
design is i mean it's designed in a way
to support all of these different
potential play styles um the sort of
tortured metaphor that i that i used to
explain
this not in the text but when i was
speaking with the developers was it's
each level is kind of like a piece of
rope and stick with me because this is a
little tortured and i realize it's
horrible but so peace rope has a
beginning and an end right i think
there's a start there's an end it can
rope in any number of directions right
but a rope really is a variety of
threads all spun together wound together
uh to create this cohesive
single unit right so the level design in
deus ex is very much the same thing
there's a you know you start at one part
of the level you need to get to another
part of the level but the number of
paths you can take in between and the
number of different approaches are
incredibly extensive to the point that
even after three hours i was talking to
other people who had played the same
portion and learning things that i
didn't discover in that amount of time
which is pretty crazy because it was not
i was playing it for three hours and
still didn't see everything is like
kind of uh just incredible um
so that was yeah that was my hands on
experience with the game along the
mission um so the fact that i was
playing it for three hours and still
didn't see everything is like
kind of uh just incredible um
so that was yeah that was my hands on
experience with the game so mata you
didn't get to play mankind divided but
you have played a lot of the series as a
whole going into it are do you have any
concerns that you you're really hoping
that they they address with the sequel
well for one thing um
one of my major concerns would have to
be
the uh enemy ai uh that was a hugely
kind of criticized factor of human
revolution
so i was actually kind of curious for
scott yeah
from your experiences how was that
yeah you know we were actually talking
about this a little earlier today in the
office um and i i would say that it's
probably a little too early to make you
know a full
ruling on exactly how good the ai is i
mean that's that's that's something that
generally gets tweaked right up until
launch um it's something that can be
improved or changed uh with relative
ease um and that said i had both good
and bad experiences with the ai like for
example um there was one mission i was
playing through uh just entirely stealth
and had the tranquilizer sniper rifle
and was hiding an event and shot a guard
and somebody sort of behind him noticed
that he collapsed and crumpled to the
ground and so he came walking over to
investigate and as he's you know stopped
and stood over the you know lifeless
body of his friend i sniped him and then
he fell asleep and fell down and
somebody else noticed that this happened
and he wandered over and eventually
there were like three or four guys in a
dog pile of just like all asleep life um
but yeah i think there's an interesting
point to be made there that maybe that's
not so much a product of poor ai as much
as it's just like how stealth mechanics
and games frequently work each other
stealth games which is like not how that
would go in real life um
but yeah i think there's an interesting
point to be made there that maybe that's
not so much a product of poor ai as much
as it's just like how stealth mechanics
and games frequently work i mean you
could do the exact same thing in most
metal gear games or splinter cell games
i mean that's just kind of a byproduct
of stealth in games the way it works
mechanically but that sort of stuck out
to me is an interesting experience with
the ai but then on the flip side of that
coin i think the ai also demonstrated
some uh
really there were some really
intelligent moments um when i went in
guns blazing they would frequently
either you know flank to get a better
position on me which is pretty standard
but also i thought was interesting they
would retreat if i was doing well like
they would actually move further back in
the level and find cover and get away
from me if i had already killed other
members of you know
other
teammates of theirs uh so i thought that
that was actually pretty impressive that
they
reacted that well instead of just
rushing at me and letting me shoot them
one by one um and i will say that
don't go in guns blazing in this game uh
you will die uh you will run out of ammo
and you will die it's very much meant to
be a cover based game and and i think
that really stems from the fact that it
is a very cerebral and strategic
experience it's not meant to be you know
it just duke nukem style blow everything
up experience um you really need to
assess the battlefield use the
environment to your to your advantage um
very tactically move among the various
uh obstacles that you can use for cover
um so that was yeah again the the ai i
think was uh was pretty impressive but i
i don't recommend running at them matt
when you were playing these games how
did you typically approach the problems
you would come up against um usually by
stealth uh though i'd love to kind of
make use of a hybrid between the two
every once in a while just to kind of
play the cat and mouse game um
that was always my preference did you
actually
scott did you ever kind of utilize
because i know you did like a combat
sort of approach and stuff yeah you ever
use a mix between them at all
interestingly so i mean the way that it
would typically work in the game is you
can
choose your upgrades as you're playing
right i mean there's an extensive
progression system it is an rpg at its
core um but because we were playing a
game or a mission from the middle of the
game they just created some preset
loadouts for us and there was a stealth
loadout a combat loadout but then also
a balanced loadout that kind of gave you
a little bit of both um
so yeah if you if you want to play that
way you absolutely can actually one one
way that i uh you know one method i used
um basically relied on exploration more
than anything uh
and i think that that would actually
serve as a nice balance between stealth
and combat because you can kind of
utilize either one depending on what you
come up against as you explore the level
um but i actually managed to make it
pretty much to the end of the mission
without encountering anybody simply by
skirting the edge of the level and
finding a wall that i could bust through
to get into the back of this theater i
was trying to infiltrate um so again it
the game does a pretty impressive job of
allowing for any play style that you can
come up with uh including sort of a
balance between stealth and combat well
coming up on the end of the stage did
you get to go into a boss battle did you
see how those mechanics did not although
i was able to talk about that with the
developers like i said so the segment
that i played was relatively short it
was clearly intended to
you know allow me to get my hands on the
the mechanics of the game just the core
gameplay uh was not indicative of the
overall experience i mean i saw very
little of the story very little of the
social aspect of the game and also
didn't play any boss battles but i i'm
well aware that that is
the
biggest single issue that people had
with human revolution so i talked about
that extensively with the developers as
well as the endings if for people who
didn't play the previous game most
people were not happy with the way that
they handled sort of the
choices at the end of the game in a sort
of mass effect 3 kind of way i try not
to spoil anything um but suffice to say
the developers were well aware of
everyone's concern and in fact they
themselves even knew at the time they
weren't completely satisfied with the
way that those
those aspects of the game turned out but
even just from building them they they
learned even before they got any
reaction from from the audience they
knew
what didn't work about it and what they
needed to change and and hopefully we
will see
those improvements uh come alive in in
mankind divided and we're also going to
get to hear more about these things i
mean you had a very extensive preview up
on the site but there's some more stuff
that we're going to be coming that's
going to be coming out of that yeah so
the preview that i put up last week was
purely a hands-on focus you know just
talking about my experience playing the
game i'm also working on a feature
that's going to be very interview driven
it's going to be a lot of my discussion
with the developers i was able to sit
down with five different members of the
core creative team discuss basically
every aspect of the game's design um so
it gets a little heady but there's a lot
of really interesting information about
their stuff about you know adam jensen's
progression the way this ties into the
overarching uh mythos of deus ex a lot
of sort of deeper material that i think
people will be very interested to read
and matt i guess our our last question
is is there anything that you want to
know from from scotter that you really
hope that they they change or that they
fix about the game just make this an
overall better experience
well it was more not so much a serious
thing though i kind of wonder myself if
there's going to be a new sort of
replacement for the classic but also
kind of cringe-worthy i never asked for
this
man that seriously like that that line
is the the cake was a lie of deus ex
just the most so i don't know who knows
i mean like i said unfortunately i got
very little exposure to the story or to
the dialogue didn't get to meet uh elias
defects as the the voice actor
um maybe someday i believe that there's
a gamespot interview with him somewhere
from back in the day but i didn't get to
talk to him unfortunately um so it's
entirely possible there will be some new
meme that emerges from this game but as
of yet we have not seen it so
someday well one of the first places
you'll be able to find that i was
probably gonna be here on gamespot and
we'll be looking to you scott matt
thanks so much for talking about the
game and i look forward to hearing more
what you guys think about it as as it
comes along so deus ex mankind divided
is due out february 23 2016 so we have a
few more previews left before we see the
final game but thanks so much for
watching
and the next thing that we're going to
be talking about
is what our giveaway is i guess we're
this is not a show this is the the end
of the show but we are doing a really
cool giveaway
of a backpack good catch what's inside
this amazing backpack so we're doing a
tomb raider themed giveaway uh there's a
backpack you see the uh oh yeah it's
good can can you see it can you guys is
it is the camera because it's invisible
camo indexes if you wouldn't like that
joke don't sweat it to win this tomb
raider themed backpack you can follow
gamespot and retweet for a chance to win
did we put anything inside
is there soon
no
i think that's there's
stuff
and i think there will be more stuff i
believe we're in the process of
gathering
random items from the office disaster
guide
a witcher comic
think about all these wonderful things
you can win inside the tomb raider
themed
backpack
we'll be filming
but ultimately it's full of your hopes
and dreams for what tomb raider is going
to be
so follow gamespot on twitter and
retweet for a chance to win this cool
tomb raider themed backpack you might
not be able to see it again it's camo so
it's yeah it's invisible throw this i
over there i didn't even notice that
happened
all right so that's the the end of the
show again scott matt thanks so much for
coming out and hopefully next week
you'll get to have danny o'dwyer back
here you'll get to learn what amazing
things he was working on and i will go
back to my other job as a part-time
robin williams impersonator
thanks so much for watching guys
you